Of course, in reality, we don't know whether a person suffers cancer,
but we can run a test like a blood test.
The outcome of it blood test may be positive or negative, but like any good test,
it tells me something about the thing I really care about--whether the person has cancer or not.
Let's say, if the person has the cancer, the test comes up positive with the probability of 0.9,
and that implies if the person has cancer, the negative outcome will have 0.1 probability
and that's because these two things have to add to 1.
I've just given you a fairly complicated notation that says the outcome of the test depends
on whether the person has cancer or not.
That is more complicated than everything else we've talked about so far.
We call this thing over here a conditional probability,
and the way to understand this is a very funny notation.
There's a bar in the middle, and the bar says what's the probability of the stuff on the left
given that we assume the stuff on the right is actually the case.
Now, in reality, we don't know whether the person has cancer or not, and in a later unit,
we're going to reason about whether the person has cancer given a certain data set,
but for now, we assume we have god-like capabilities.
We can tell with absolute certainty that the person has cancer,
and we can determine what the outcome of the test is.
This is a test that isn't exactly deterministic--it makes mistakes,
but it only makes a mistake in 10% of the cases, as illustrated by the 0.1 down here.
Now, it turns out, I haven't fully specified the test.
The same  test might also be applied to a situation where the person does not have cancer.
So this little thing over here is my shortcut of not having cancer.
And now, let me say the probability of the test giving me a positive results--a false positive result
when there's no cancer is 0.2.
You can now tell me what's the probability of a negative outcome in case
we know for a fact the person doesn't have cancer, so please tell me.